hello if you have found the ideas i
discussed
interesting and useful perhaps you might
consider purchasing my recently released
book
beyond order 12 more rules for life
available from penguin random house in
print
or audio format you could use the links
we provide below or
buy through amazon or at your local
bookstore
this new book beyond order provides what
i hope
is a productive and interesting walk
through ideas that are both
philosophically and
sometimes spiritually meaningful as well
as being
immediately implementable and practical
beyond order can be read and understood
on its own
but also builds on the concepts that i
developed in my previous books
12 rules for life and before that
maps of meaning thanks for listening
and enjoy the podcast
[Music]
so today i have the privilege of having
as a guest dr bjorn lomberg
who i've spoken with before on my
podcast and
who was recently on my daughter's
podcast michaela peterson as well
and uh i came across bjorn's work
it's got to be six or seven years ago
now when i was working for
a u.n panel the canadian panel devoted
to
analyzing economic problems in a
hypothetically sustainable manner it was
for the
secretarial secretary general's report
on
sustainable economic development which
was i think put out in 2016 anyhow while
i was working on that project
i read a lot of books on the
various environmental crises that
apparently beset us
dozens of books and
of all the people i read
i think dr lomberg
dr lomberg's work was the most
compelling and that was partly
one of the things i realized when i was
working for this un committee we were
trying to
write the narrative to restructure the
narrative
regarding what should be priorities for
international consideration over the
next
30 to 100 years and what i realized
while working on that was that
there were very few people in the world
that were trained to think at that level
um people just don't have the expertise
to do that we don't have the methodology
we don't know how to specify the
problems and we don't know how to
specify the solutions and we don't know
how to rank order the problems in terms
of their
um let's say they're the degree to which
they're crucial and we don't know how to
rank order the solutions
in terms of their appropriateness and
the only person that i
ran across who had developed a
methodology for doing this
which is of crucial importance to
develop that methodology
was bjorn and the think tank the
copenhagen
consensus center which we'll get him to
talk about
um and bjorn maybe you could elaborate
let's
see there's lots of problems we have
lots of problems human beings have lots
of problems some of them are familial
some of them are
uh civic at the city level say some of
them are at the state level some of them
are at the national level and a handful
are at the international level and
there's a good rule of thumb which is
that we shouldn't solve
family problems at the international
level right you should
work at the lowest possible level but
some problems are international and
at least you could make that case and
you've been wrestling with this since
um 19 the mid-1990s and you wrote a
whole bunch of books the structure of
solutions in the iterated prisoners
dilemma i think was the first one
the skeptical environmentalist which i
think really established your reputation
and your notoriety for that matter
global crisis global solutions cool it
uh rethink hiv how to spend 75 billion
dollars to make the world a better place
which i really liked i thought that was
a great book
like truly a great book rajasthan
priorities bangladesh priorities
haiti prioritizes and andhra pradesh
prioritizes and your latest book
which we'll talk about a fair bit today
is false alarm
how climate change panic costs us
trillions hurts the poor and fails to
fix the planet
and so well with that introduction i'm
going to let you talk about your work
for a bit
hey thank you it's great to see you
again jordan so
look what i try to do and really i have
a big organization
uh uh well actually for a small
organization but lots and lots
of researchers that work hard on all
these problems
as simply as as you as you say we don't
have infinite resources we can't do
everything first
so it's incredibly important that we
have this conversation about saying
if you are to spend an extra dollar or a
rupee or whatever your currency is
where can you spend that and do the most
good
first because as you also point out
there are lots of problems
and and and while we tend to think about
them in the international arena
of course most problems actually hit
people on a very personal level
it kills them and and so you know one of
the things
i i find slightly ironic uh as we've
just come out of 2020 and everybody has
been very very concerned
about covet and rightly so it's a big
challenge
uh but at the same time of course every
year
about the same number of people die as
i've died from covet last year
every year the same number of people die
from tuberculosis
this is a very simple disease we've
known about it it's probably killed
about a billion people over the last 200
years
so it's probably one of the biggest
kills of humanity
and we know how to fix it we fixed it in
the rich world which is why we don't
worry about it anymore
but it's also very cheap to fix in the
developing world
but because it never gets any attention
we don't talk very much about it we
don't do very much about and that's why
1.6 million people every year
die from tuberculosis and so my point
simply is to say
let's have a discussion about saying if
you were to spend an extra dollar
would you do the most good if you spent
it on tuberculosis
or in covet or on climate or on
infrastructure or on the many many other
solutions that are out there and and
what we do is we simply work with lots
of economists
to take a look at what is the cost of a
solution
and how much good will that deliver not
just in terms
of economics that is how much better off
will we be or how less
worse off will we be but also how much
better will we be off
socially that's typically people not
dying people not being sick
people not having to pay their doctors
not experiencing the loss of a loved one
and also environmentally that's not so
much relevant for
for tuberculosis but of course when it
comes to deforestation or
loss of wetlands and the air pollution
indoor air pollution and many of the
other problems of the world also have
an environmental component we try to add
up all of those
and so basically say how much will this
cost
how much good will it do when you
incorporate all of these things
and turn them into dollars and then you
can basically say for every dollar you
spend
you do this much good of social benefit
and then we simply ask if there are lots
of solutions where you'll spend a dollar
and maybe do
a dollar and a half of good for the
world that's nice
but there are some solutions where you
can spend a dollar and do
hundreds of dollars of good shouldn't we
focus on the hundreds of dollars first
the place where you make much much more
good for every
resource you spend that's really the
thinking it's not it's not rocket
science but we just don't
think about it very often it kind of is
rocket science because
one of the things you want to do when
you send a rocket into space is make
sure that it doesn't explode
and what that means is that you have to
pay unbelievable attention to the
details i think it was an
o-ring malfunction that brought down the
challenger
yeah so and so an o-ring was rocket
science in that situation and
what really struck me when i started to
think about international problems was
precisely this lack of methodology
so i'm going to recapitulate the claims
you just made so that the listeners are
and viewers are very clear about like
you make a number of assumptions and
all of those assumptions are
questionable but anyone who questions
them bears the burden of coming up with
a better set of
assumptions and justifying them and so
you know you can imagine someone
objecting to your
rather casual um acceptance of the idea
that you can
put a cost value on all of these
problems
you know anybody who might object to
who might have some emotional objections
even to something like the monetary
system
and to capitalism for example might be
appalled at the idea that you could put
a dollar value to human life
essentially but in the absence of a
better solution
well that's exactly what i mean you have
to have a better solution so
your first claim is that we have limited
resources
okay so that seems reasonable we have
limited time we have limited energy we
have limited resources
that are at our disposal as individuals
and as states and so we can't devote
an infinite amount of resources to every
problem so that seems pretty much
pretty much clear um if we're going to
solve problems we might as well start
with the ones that are the most serious
so we've got to figure out how to define
that
then we want to concentrate on the
serious problems that we can
fix and then we want to concentrate on
the serious problems that we can fix
most effectively so that we have some
resources left over to solve other
problems
okay so let's start with the problem set
itself
so for example in your book false alarm
you talk about climate change and you
uh uh you you're a supporter of the
claim that
there is going to be climate change of
approximately the
degree so to speak that the
international climate commission
projects and you also
accept the claim that much of that is
man-made
and but then you situate climate change
as a problem
as a problem in a host of other problems
so i'd like to know how you
came up with the set of problems to
begin with
so so very clearly it's it's impossible
to enumerate
all the problems that we have uh but
what we try to do is
uh we've taken our starting point the
un's uh different
definitions so for the uh the sdgs the
last set of
goals that the un has has uh has uh used
the ones that are running from 2016 to
2030.
these are sustainable development goals
right so they've basically looked across
a wide range of areas so
talking about uh health obviously a big
issue
uh poverty obviously a big issue uh the
the the issue of education the issue of
being able to
uh live securely that is without
violence and
in many different ways and they
enumerate a lot of different other
things
uh clearly avoiding loss of biodiversity
uh
avoiding living on an uninhabitable
planet like climate change
many of these other things now i'm not
saying that this is a perfect list
that's
it's made by a committee uh but it's
probably one of the best ways that we
can say
humanity has tried to enumerate all the
different challenges
that we're uh that we're facing right so
that's the political aspect of this is
a consensus there's been somewhat of a
consensus
with regards to the set of problems even
if not with regards to their
prioritization
and so absolutely the u.n has made
itself open to some degree
to to its constituent members to list
whatever problems they see as pressing
and those would include women's rights
and diversity and
oceanic management and well virtually
every problem that you can think of that
might have hit the headlines
or been a target of media attention over
the last
say two or three decades and so
again people might quibble with that
list but then it's
instrumental that they develop a better
list and justify it so you start with
the un list and
and that's been derived as a consequence
of
lobbying pressure and political
machination and all all those sorts of
things and
hypothetically that's good enough and
then the next
question is how to address these how to
and
i was very frustrated when i first
encountered that list of of
of goals because i thought well there is
no possible way that these can all be
addressed in the next
30 years with any degree of success it's
just too complex
we have to start somewhere the problem
with that is that
as soon as you say that you have to
start somewhere then
you take one need above all others
and you say that those who lobbied for
that particular need take priority and
you need a justification for that that's
that's something other than power
struggle or political
expediency or or uh
you know even effective messaging you it
might be nice to have a more
hands-off objective method okay so then
you
you organized a team of economists
fundamentally right why economists and
not biologists say or
so you definitely need all the knowledge
from biologists especially when you're
talking about things that impact the
natural world
you need to talk to epidemiologists when
you're talking about diseases you need
to talk to doctors also about diseases
you need to talk to educational experts
when you talk about education
but the crucial bit that's connecting
all of them is to talk about
what are the resource needs that is
basically
how much money are we going to have to
pay in order to get a solution
when you talk about global warming or a
solution for education
or a solution for tuberculosis or covet
or any other thing
so what we're talking to is all those
economists who do that so climate
economist or education economist
or health economist these are all guys
who interface with all of the specific
knowledge
but they also study how much is this
going to cost
and how effective is this solution going
to be
so it's basically about saying what can
you do about global warming or what can
you do about covet
remember no solution is going to fix all
of the problem
most solutions will fix part of the
problem and so what we're saying is
what will a realistically best sort of
effort look like how much will it solve
and how much will it cost
and then we try to estimate what's the
relative value that you provided to the
world and
as you started off saying that's a
difficult task
but it is crucial if we want to know
that we're not just focused
on the topics that have uh the most cute
animals or
the people who scream the loudest in the
media but
actually know what works a postmodern
critic of your work might claim that
it's um inerratically contaminated with
the bias brought to it by the discipline
that you chose to do this election and
by the
um what would you what would you say by
the
unexamined political motivations of the
participants those being the economists
but
you don't rely on the judgment of one
economist
you have a sequence of economists
analyze these problems that's correct
and then you aggregate across their
findings i believe that's the method
yes and again look it's impossible to
imagine that
anyone can do this entirely objectively
so as you're pointing out
clearly economists come with a certain
way of looking at the world they
typically start take the starting point
of saying
there's limited resources how much will
the resources do here
how what's the opportunity cost so
typically uh for instance if you want to
vaccinate uh children and third world
countries
it means that their moms will have to
take off typically the whole day
walk with their kid to this place where
they're going to get vaccinated
that has a significant cost for the
family you need to incorporate that cost
economists will tell you not taking that
into account
is a failure recognizing that's part of
the cost of vaccination
but of course it is only one way of
looking at it i happen to think that
it's a fairly convincing way and as
again
as you point out at least you have to
come up with another way of looking this
if you want to uh criticize and say we
should do something yeah well that can't
be reiterated too many times is that
it isn't good enough to point out the
hypothetical flaws of this approach
it's only good enough to put forward a
viable alternative
and i haven't seen a viable alternative
no right now
the way the world organizes its
priorities is very much about who gets
to set the agenda who have
the cute examples the things that we
care the most about
the things that are easy to get into the
media and so on and surely
that's not necessarily the best way to
decide how we spend
trillions of dollars on the on on global
issues
so what we're simply trying to do is to
give the world a sense of
how much good can you actually do if you
spend money
really smartly on climate or if you
spend it really smartly on education or
if you spend it really smartly
on all these other things and then we
have a good sense of it
look at the end of the day it's still
going to be a political battle
it's still going to be a discussion
about what you know captivates
people's attention there's a reason why
we haven't talked about tuberculosis for
about a hundred years
but of course once a covet hits rich
people
and hits home we talk a lot more about
infectious diseases i'm not saying it's
wrong we should definitely talk about
how we deal with covet
but i think we should perhaps talk more
about also how do we deal with
tuberculosis
uh not only because it doesn't uh
affect rich people but because it
affects a lot of people around the world
so getting that conversation going
getting a sense of the proportion of the
problem
getting a sense of what can we do what's
the cost
what is the total benefit in terms of
making
economies making people and making the
planet or the environment
better off what are the benefits there
what are the cost in getting that
balance
is crucial okay now my sense is that
you're
tell me if i'm wrong but my sense is
that you're often
lumped in by people who have made
climate change the center of their
ideological universe you're often lumped
in with
uh climate change
deniers of questionable motive
and this is the the first
question might be um
do you think it's fair to do that and if
not
why not and if it's not fair why
why does it happen so there's definitely
a lot of people who just
approach what i say and many others say
oh it's just a deny he doesn't accept
the
reality of global warming and that's
just simply false
i think what has happened is that
climate
con the climate conversation has become
so politicized
that to many people it's just simply
easier to
uh to sort of uh uh what do you say just
get rid of that an inconvenient argument
by saying oh you're a denier and somehow
being able to shut down the conversation
exclusively by saying oh bjorn is a deny
i'm not a denier
i've very clearly been stating ever ever
since my first book the skeptical
environmentalist as you mentioned
global warming is real it's man-made it
is a problem
i'm simply accepting what the u.n
climate panel the ipc is telling us
about global warming
what i'm arguing is how much
will a potential solution cost and how
much
good will that solution deliver to
humanity
so the real question here is are we
spending lots of resources doing not
very much good for climate
when we could be spending those
resources much better on climate that is
doing much more to actually tackle the
climate problem and of course also
that we could spend those resources and
do much much more
for the whole world with its many many
other problems
those are two important questions i
think and the reason why they matter so
much is because
in many ways uh you know if you're just
going to talk very very rough numbers
the world spends about 150 billion
dollars
on all the big problems in the world
uh you know from uh peacekeeping forces
uh to dealing with malaria and
tuberculosis to uh
hiv to education to uh
gender equality to many many other
problems but
we spend in the order of 400 billion or
more
per year on climate change so if you
look at the
money that we spend on doing good in the
world the
vast amount of that money goes to
climate change
so if we get it wrong on climate we're
really getting it wrong
on how we tackle the world's big
problems okay so i'm going to read
something from the
u.n climate panel that you quote in your
book
for most economic sectors the impact of
climate change
will be small relative to the impacts of
other drivers
such as changes in population age income
technology relative prices lifestyle
regulation governance and many other
aspects of socioeconomic development
okay so that's the ipc
c panel itself that pen
those words now you'd never guess that i
don't think by
um you wouldn't infer that
codicil if you only paid attention to
the way that
the climate change projections are
covered by the media
and so now we've got a a psychological
question and
i suppose this is partly a question of
the problems of communication
so it when you're trying to solve a
problem you've got two problems one is
to generate the solution the practical
solution
that might be analogous to producing a
new technology but then you have the
problem of communicating about that
technology so that people purchase it
so you have a production problem and a
sales and marketing problem
and you've you've got a production
problem and a sales and marketing
problem
now you'd think that
one of the things that you point out in
the introduction for example is that
the the cost of climate change
interventions often involve an increase
in energy prices
and that increase in energy price falls
most heavily on
the poor and you make a credible case
a strong case i would say that much of
the climate change intervention
uh as currently conceptualized is going
to further
impoverish the poor and this
make this really confuses me i would say
because
i don't think it's unreasonable to
suggest that most of the
motivation most of the efforts to put
climate change at the forefront of
modern
consideration comes from the left
you think that's reasonable yeah okay
definitely what's happening
okay then you'd also think that the
primary concern of the left would be
the absolute or the relative poverty of
the most
impoverished or relatively impoverished
people
so i can't understand why since you've
continually made the case that climate
change policy has con
presently construed is differentially
going to affect the poor
that that doesn't attenuate the left's
insistence that climate change is the
predominant problem and now i have a
hypothesis about that and my hypothesis
i don't think it's particularly original
and it could easily be wrong
but i think that there's an intrinsic
anti-capitalism
that is uh contaminating the
discussion about climate change and
perhaps even the science
and that the fundamental goal is to
advance a criticism of free market
capitalism by other means
and climate change actually produces
that outcome
that practical outcome and if it happens
to
negatively affect the poor then that's
an okay price to pay
even though that's perverse because the
whole reason for the criticism of
capitalism
to begin with hypothetically is because
of desire to help out
either the absolutely impoverished or
the relatively impoverished
so that leaves me with something like
resentment as the only other motivation
now
you know i don't think any of that's
necessarily right but i haven't been
able to come up with a better hypothesis
so
you face tremendous opposition in your
work
and i don't understand why
what's going on yeah it's a good
question i i
i tend to take people on their on on
face value of what they
uh of what they talk about i think
there's a number of different things
that are going on
so a lot of people i i think i
i meet a lot of uh really well-meaning
uh uh very very concerned people on on
climate change
they basically believe uh that the world
is ending
unless we do something about global
warming i mentioned in my book that a
new survey
across the world shows almost half the
world's population believe that it's now
likely that global warming will lead to
the extinction
of the human race that's a huge and
absolutely
unwarranted uh argument but you know if
you believe
this is the end of the world everything
else
moves off the the conversation if global
warming is the end of the world if it's
the sort of asteroid that hurtling
towards earth we should just drop
everything else and just you know send
up bruce willis and
and you know do something about that
asteroid so the idea here is to
recognize
uh and i've heard sensible people say
look there's going to be poor people in
we'll we'll help them then right now we
need to help
global warming that makes sense if this
is the end of the world that we're
trying to get rid of
that's why one of the big points that i
try to make in the book
is to say that is not what the u.n
climate panel is telling us
actually as you just mentioned climate
change is a problem
but it's a fairly small one compared to
most of the other things that we talk
about
we never talk about our pension problems
but those are probably
going to be much much bigger than
climate change
the other part so just to just to finish
your your your
your conversation about the poor i think
that when we were
not nearly as scared about global
warming in some way you can you could
argue
that the reason why we've become so
scared is because the media
the selling argument of climate change
has just been way too successful
it's become the self-perpetuating
machine that just takes any storm or
anything that happens out there and say
see global warming and make us all
believe that the end is nigh
but before that i think there was a real
challenge in
in the way especially the left was very
worried about global warming
but also worried about the world's poor
and i think
it was simply an oversight that we focus
so much on global warming and so little
on
on on the world's poor and i think if
you're going to be very rude about it
you could possibly say it's also a
little bit because
we care about our own children so our
own children we worry will grow up in a
world where it's global warming and it's
going to be terrible for them
compared to the world's poor which are
mostly not our kids it's someone else's
kids
uh typically in africa or latin america
or in
or in southeast asia uh so in some sense
this is really
i'm gonna pick my kids over all the
other uh
uh uh unfortunate kids i think that was
also a big driver
and i try to argue both of these and get
people to realize
maybe that's not the right priority for
our planet okay i do
think that generally speaking it's best
to take people
at face value because uh to not do so
means that you're not extending a hand
of trust and it gets you into a terribly
complex cognitive situation
but uh but i would point out that you
did question their motives at the end of
that answer you know
saying that perhaps people are more
concerned with their own children
and willing to sacrifice the world's
poor so to speak
um in their prior time prioritization as
a consequence of that
um i
looked at at a potential potential dark
motivation of
of a kind of lurking anti-capitalism
another possibility perhaps is that
a lot of the problems that you list
are do fall into that into the same
conceptual category
as the world's poor the hypothetical
person that you described
said well there'll still be poor people
in 2030 and we can worry about them
and so you might say that you can't make
poverty into an apocalyptic catastrophe
plausibly and you can't even make
tuberculosis into a
cataclysmic uh problem or apocalyptic
problem
um plausibly we we know how that's going
to go
it's going to stay pretty much the same
way that it is you know
barring mutation and and but with
climate change
there's a there's a non-zero possibility
of cataclysmic collapse
um the the green
the the greenland ice pack melts and
slides into the ocean
or the uh the gulf stream reverses
or something like that and and and
we get a situation where positive
feedback loops spiral out of control and
everything
comes to a everything culminates in
catastrophe
it might be that we don't know how to
deal with
a problem that has a non-zero
probability of being infinite
and and and that is a good com that that
is a good theoretical conversation
my take on that is is really twofold
it's
it's partly i think it's just simply a
question of imagination
everything when you run it out to 2100
has a non-zero probability of going
really really wrong
uh so one very good uh argument would be
to say
uh take hiv aids uh which laid bare much
of uh
sub-saharan africa if you imagine if we
did nothing about hiv aids
you could very easily imagine one or
more states
in africa collapsing over the 21st
century
throw in some bioterrorism and some
geoengineering
uh sorry some geo uh you uh some uh
bioengineering
and you know you can get a catastrophe
you know that it drives up some
terrorists who are gonna
basically eradicate humanity you can
come up with
almost any kind of scenario that will
end the world
and clearly we also have many many other
scenarios that we're not
particularly worried about you know one
would be north korea
uh that seems a non-plausible outcome
that they could
uh end up ending the world if we don't
do something about uh north korea i'm
not sure what that
something would be but the point here is
to say that it's very clear
we're saying yeah we're going to be a
little worried about north korea but not
very much
okay so so are you are you criticizing
my hypothesis or are you pointing
so like because i i said that that
climate change seems to slide pretty
easily into an apocalyptic vision
and i one interpretation of your
criticism would be well
um that's not valid it's not valid to
make it apocalyptic like that because
many other things can be made
apocalyptic
but do you think that it's plausible
potentially that it is easier to do that
with climate change
or and i mean it's not clear why
maybe it's because it also involves the
non-human actors in the world
and people feel additional guilt about
that
so do we have a do we have a rule of
thumb
that something like well when we're
discussing
practical moves forward we don't get to
extrapolate from the present
apocalyptically and say that this
problem is so severe that
it requires an infinite amount of
resources or
it is it morally obligates us to devote
an infinite number of resources to its
solution
we don't get to play that game that was
exactly my point so
there's there's been a wonderful
discussion between uh
a harvard professor uh who was arguing
essentially that
point that global warming might be
infinitely bad so we should be spending
infinitely
of resources on it and a yale uh
economics professor uh william nordhaus
who got the nobel prize in climate
economics
and his point was exactly to say look
there are infinity
infinities everywhere else uh you know
so uh you might have heard
elon musk is worrying about the fact
that ai robots will
will take over uh will will possibly
take over the world
uh there's the possibility that uh
nanotech will lead to grey goo
taking over the entire world there's
potential lurking
catastrophes in everything we do you
can't and that was nordhouse's point you
can't just take one and say
i'm gonna spend infinity over here
because you should be spending infinity
on pretty much everything else of course
that doesn't actually compute and so
what
real people do all the time is we're
faced with things that have a tiny
probability
of going really really badly we spend
more resources on them we try to find
more ways to tackle them smartly but we
also recognize there's no way we're
going to get rid of
all apocalyptic problems we simply have
to be
smart about it and in my book i talk
about how we should also be smart about
climate change
if you worry about the apocalyptic uh
prosper
prospects of global warming the only way
to fix that is by investigating not
doing but investigating
geoengineering which is basically a way
of being able to without climate policy
be able to stabilize the planet's uh uh
climate
right and i don't i don't have the
feeling that geo engineering solutions
are going to be an easy sell
even to people who are apocalyptically
minded and
maybe it's maybe it's because they
envisioned geoengineering apocalypses
as a cause and they and they do but what
you also have to remember is a lot of
people will tell you
i believe global warming is the end of
the world and certainly lots of kids are
really really scared about this and i
think we should come back to talk about
how this is
this is just simply not real but i often
find it
really surprising that if you really
really really believe
this could be the end of the world why
is it you're not advocating the only
technology that we know right now
how to fix global warming with which is
nuclear power
uh why is it you're not just putting up
nuclear power everywhere
now i'm actually not arguing for that
because economically
nuclear power is not very advantageous
but if you think this is the end of the
world i wonder why it is
that you would be arguing let's do the
policies that haven't worked for the
last 30 years
let's put up solar panels wind turbines
that cover a couple percent of the
world's
energy consumption and that may by 2040
cover maybe even four maybe even five
percent of that
energy consumption if you really worried
about it you would be using
the technologies that would actually
work and the fact that you don't
also kind of belies that even though you
talk a lot about these
these end of the world scenarios you
don't quite believe them because you'd
be a lot well you also focused on
solutions you also make the point in the
introduction
that when you ask people by poll
how concerned they are about global
warming many there's many people
like a majority of people if i remember
correctly who are very concerned about
global warming
but if you ask them how much they would
be willing to spend to ameliorate it
i think the average american agreed to
spend 24 dollars if i remember correctly
from your book
and so then that does the problem then
is by pointing that out you belie your
other claim which is that you want to
take people at face value now you've got
a real problem in that
situation because you can take them at
face value with regards to their
explicit claims about what they
what they're afraid of which is global
warming but then
equally explicitly they tell you they
don't want to spend any money on it and
so then you have to wonder well which of
those two competing claims do you
actually believe
i would tend to go with the one that
actually it hasn't
saying that you're afraid of global
warming has zero cost
spending money on it has a cost
obviously so the
the thing is as soon as you put a cost
to it then you find out that people
don't
appear to believe it they're not
concerned so
the question then is well what what does
saying that they're concerned about by
them and it
it might be something like well this is
again not a particularly original
thought but it's moral virtue
to advertise that i'm the sort of person
who's
intelligent enough to conceptualize
global concerns
and empathic and noble enough to be
concerned by them
and then you say well what are you doing
about it and the answer is
well i'm not doing anything and then you
say well then i don't buy your claim but
that's pretty rude and
two people who get together who are both
concerned about global warming aren't
going to be
criticizing each other's lack of
diligent attention to the sacrifices
they can just embrace one another and
i'm not being entirely cynical about
that
i know why people advertise virtue and
people are relatively virtuous and so
it's not such a terrible thing to
advertise it but
it does seem to interfere in this
particular situation
with practical movement forward now one
of the things you drive home continually
is that there are real costs to getting
this wrong
the costs are the money spent and
what that money could have been spent on
instead
so maybe you could make a case for
for everyone who's watching what what do
you see as the proper set of priorities
where do we
where do we as a species get the most
bang for the buck with regards to these
international problems what are the top
10 things we should be
concentrating on yeah so
so absolutely just to just to give you a
sense of of
of the uh of the 24 dollars you were
just talking about before
that people are not willing to spend
very much uh i think that's one of the
reasons why
for instance our carbon tax is so hard
to do carbon tax is
one of the smart solutions for climate
change but it also very makes it very
explicit that you're spending lots of
money
so instead what most people support is
that we should be
subsidizing green energy that we should
be subsidizing
uh electric cars that we should be doing
a lot of other things
that make you feel virtuous it doesn't
feel like it costs all that much
but it actually ends up costing huge
amounts of resources
so so while people saying they're not
willing to spend very much
their sentiment actually allows politics
to end up spending huge amounts of money
so this really matters
so sorry you asked me what are the
things we should be spending our
resources and so that also means what
are we sacrificing if we concentrate too
much on
the moral virtue of driving a tesla for
example which is a clear status symbol
very expensive and not obviously related
to ameliorating climate change
what are we sacrificing so
as long as we're driving this tesla
because the government and that's
typically almost everywhere in the world
because the government has spent five or
ten thousand dollars
on subsidizing us in order to make us
afford
to drive this tesla that's ten thousand
dollars that couldn't go to other things
either in our
own states our own nations where we
obviously could have spent
according to what the uh the uh uh
decision-making process would decide you
know on better education and better care
for our elderly
on better covet uh uh care
uh right now there are lots of other
things that are demanding attention
but what we tried to look at was where
could you spend this
globally and i'm going to talk about a
few things because i
uh you know i'm sure we can get back to
more of them so one of the things that
we talked about was
free trade so free trade we know
is one of the reasons why almost
everyone has gotten rich the basic point
is
that instead of me trying to do
everything i
specialize i do one thing and then i
have a baker bread my
uh bake my bread i have a butcher uh do
my meat uh if i'm not vegetarian and
you know you do all these other things
and you have all these specialists doing
it
having it on an international scale
means even
more opportunity to have smarter
people do what they do best for everyone
else
and that's why we've gotten rich that's
why china has lifted about what 700
million people
out of absolute poverty over the last 30
years which is one of the
biggest achievements in the world and
it's impossible not to be
very very impressive just simply on the
humanity of that project
and of course we should be doing more of
that
but unfortunately we have you know
for a variety of reasons trump is
obviously a big part of this but it's
also
it started way before trump uh the the
resentment towards free trade the sense
that this was
wrong has not only meant that
many people in the rich world has become
less better off than they otherwise
could have been
but it's also meant that we have left a
lot of people especially in africa and
south
south asia much less well-off we should
be spending some of our resources
on making sure that we get more free
trade not less free trade how do
we do that how do we do that effectively
and the simple way that we do that
unfortunately
is by subsidizing of agriculture so
one of the best most vested interests
against free trade has turned out to be
agriculture it's agriculture in the eu
and the us japan many other places
because they don't want to have
that competition look from a private
part of you i understand that if i was a
farmer i wouldn't want
you know cheap uh uh cheap agriculture
produce come in
and essentially eradicate my business
model so we need to recognize that we
need to subsidize these people we
probably
also need to subsidize other people the
people who would otherwise have lost
their jobs
so there's an enormous amount of money
that needs to be spent
i got confused um are you speaking about
eradicating
agricultural subsidies in the west or
are you speaking about subsidizing
agricultural
uh productivity in third world countries
or
re i i i missed the i missed the
mechanics there
so sorry i'm talking about subsidizing
the people who would otherwise block
more free trade so this is basically
subsidizing
rich western farmers to make sure that
they're okay
with more right so if their livelihood
is endangered
by the necessity of allowing for
competition on the agricultural market
you just buy them out
like you might do with fishermen who are
over fishing the ocean
yes exactly and this is not a potential
this is not
perfect by any means but it's a way to
actually solve the problem of getting
more
of the stuff that will help humanity any
idea what the ben
what are the benefit is of that compared
to the cost and is that calculable
yes so we we made the estimate that for
every dollar you spend on these
subsidies
you will help the world about two
thousand dollars
uh basically because you can generate an
enormous amount
of internal growth so we estimate that
you could actually make every person in
the developing world
about a thousand dollar richer per
person
per year in 15 years that's it okay so
wait
we're going to slow down there because
those are unbelievable those are
unbelievably
massive claims okay so you said
to subsidize rich agricultural producers
in the west to the tune of a dollar a
year
buys you a thousand dollars in increased
revenue
globally two thousand it's a two
thousand to one return
yes and this is basically because this
is this is the world bank's uh
dynamic uh uh trade models that show
that once you get a society
that's able to trade internationally and
openly
you also get enhanced growth within
those countries so that means
they by themselves get to be better so
that
and these would mostly be poor countries
that would also be a lot of rich
countries but these would mostly
actually help
the world's poor because they have the
most catching up to do and they will
then
be much better off not only would that
be better for them because if you're
poor
a thousand dollars is a lot better than
if you're rich getting another thousand
dollars
but also because it will help them
generate all the other things they would
like to have education health
uh resilience to global warming so
the whole point here is to recognize
that this is one of the things
that are hard to have a discussion about
there are very few people
are advocating global uh free trade
there are lots of people advocating
against it
but we need to recognize this is one of
the things that have helped
pull out most people of poverty that we
know could do even more in the future
and that we have a real opportunity to
achieve
so that well you don't have ice flow
abandoned cuddly polar bears as
as portraits of of the farmers that
you're going to help abstractly in third
world countries
so you have a sales and marketing
problem there and that's a real problem
right um
you know what it's it's interesting that
the economic models
don't take into account the difficulty
of propagating the message
you know you know what i mean is that
because there is a sales and marketing
problem there and it's not trivial
and it might be that a dollar spent in
agricultural subsidies
to rich farmers in the west would
produce that two thousand dollar return
but
the question might be how much money
would you have to spend
advertising that before people would
believe it and that that's a cru
it's a crucial question you know with a
with a standard
entrepreneurial product i don't think
it's unreasonable to estimate that
65 to 95 of the
cost is in sales and marketing
you know five percent production and
that's a that's a great argument so in
some sense you could argue
what we try to do with the copenhagen
consensus where we make these priority
lists
is just simply give you the raw data
for what would academically be the
smartest things to invest in but you're
absolutely right
there's no cute and cuddly uh you know
selling points to
free trade and and actually to most of
our top
outcomes so let me just give you a few
of the other ones so
the second best is family planning uh
and probably also basic emergency care
to women
uh this will deliver about a hundred
dollars back for every dollar i think
that would also be extremely attractive
to people on the left
it should be attracted to everyone yeah
yes because
look remember right now about 400
000 mothers die in childbirth uh and
about two million kids die
in the first 28 days of their life here
on earth
and we know we could save many of these
not all of them but
many of these by simple measures uh you
know for instance making sure that you
don't get
that the the pregnant women don't get uh
high blood pressure pre-eclampsia and
eclampsia
which kills more than a hundred thousand
women every year
uh by by simple emergency measures when
you come into a facility
give birth and you have a problem if you
have
simple procedures to make sure that that
problem can be dealt with often
with fairly cheap uh you don't need more
doctors you just need
nurses or even assistant helpers you can
do a lot of these things we know that
you can do this for very low cost
and then again if you have there's about
215 million people
women who don't have access to
prevention
so family planning if you could get them
family planning not all of them would
use family planning all of the time
but it would mean that they would space
their kids better they would be able to
give more investment into each one of
their kids
that would get them better educated
there would be a lot of
knock-on effects but mostly this would
mean
that a lot of moms wouldn't die in
childbirth and their children that they
do
uh give birth to would have better lives
and again we estimate this would cost
about three billion dollars a year
but it would pay dividends both in terms
of saving moms
saving kids but also growing the economy
because of what's
known as the demographic dividend if you
have slightly fewer kids
you have more productivity because you
have the same amount of capital but
if you're kids that means you get to be
faster
richer that's essentially what china has
done in a sort of
boosted way by their one uh one child
policy i'm not advocating that at all
but it's a it's a it gives you a good
sort of insight
then there are lots of health things we
talked about tuberculosis
we could probably spend a dollar on
tuberculosis
and help people not die help people
being better off
help families not dealing with tragedies
of losing their mom and dad it's
typically
uh you know people in their middle ages
that die from tuberculosis
every dollar spent would avoid about 43
dollars
of social benefits uh sorry would
generate
43 of of social benefits if you look at
uh childhood immunization uh we've we've
stopped a lot of the really damaging uh
uh childhood diseases so we've gone from
a world where about
12 million children died just in
1980 to now only
about five million children die every
year
below the age of five but clearly that's
still way too many
we could probably save a million
children for a billion dollars a year
just think about that we estimate that
for for every dollar spent there
you do about sixty dollars worth of good
so again
the whole point here is to recognize
there are lots of lots of amazing things
that you can do
and i was letting my internal cynic
uh respond to your arguments and trying
to adopt the position of someone who
might be critical of them
i know that
arguments for ameliorating the lot of
the poor that were put forth in the 60s
were often
counter mended by the claims often of
environmentalists
that you don't want to help the poor
because they'll breed more and that will
just
re lead to more of the kind of problems
that you're trying to solve and so
you know what the question might be why
would someone object to saving a million
children a year through immunization or
i think you said two million children as
a consequence of enhanced maternal care
and i can imagine similar arguments like
that being raised you know whether
consciously or
or implicitly um
but those things should be made implicit
so so
let i would encourage people who are
watching this or listening to this
you know a lot of you have chopped up my
um youtube videos into small videos
and sometimes animated sections of them
and otherwise distributed them
bjorn just outlined four the four
the top four investment strategies for a
better planet and
it might be useful to consider
ways that that can be that that
information can be distributed as widely
as possible i mean bjorn's writing is
books
but those sell at how many books if you
don't mind me asking how many copies of
false alarm did you sell
i think it's in the it's 10 15 000
thereabouts
right so that's that's a good that's a
good selling book from an academic book
perspective
but it's a drop in the bucket you know
right i mean
and i'm that's not a criticism obviously
what about total for your books
so it's uh you know uh two three hundred
thousand
or right right and so well a good
youtube video will get
a million views and if this was chopped
up properly maybe it would get five or s
you know five to ten million views so
that would be good but
we we don't wanna
have you thought about allying yourself
with an advertising firm
so we we've talked to some of those uh
there's been
people uh uh come in asking how can we
help can we
help do some of this and and what i find
is
that when when it ends up part partly uh
these advertising firms
uh sort of retract their offers when
they start realizing this is really
complicated that they
that it's not just you know the the cute
polar bear and the ice flow
uh kind of argument um and i get that
and part of it
of course is also that unlike
when you talk to someone who's just
saying we should do more about this
a good thing we should you know save
more moms or we should do
more about climate change we're the guys
who actually say you should do this
before this and that always antagonizes
people i think it's the only
intellectually honest argument because
we have limited resources so we're
simply saying
do this first do this work don't do this
first
don't do this first i think that's
important but that always creates a lot
more antagonism and i think that's one
of the reasons why
this is a much harder argument uh to
make
and obviously my whole book on climate
is very much
from the you don't you don't have the
problem of having to say no
if you stay in the hypothetical you know
that's another advantage to not actually
trying to solve a problem when you're
making a moral claim that you're
concerned about it
because you can be concerned about
global warming in world poverty and
and uh the lack of education of women
and
a host of other issues and never make a
sacrifice in your concerns
as long as you actually don't try to
practically address those problems
because then you're faced with the
horrible necessity of prioritization
and maybe that is part of what makes you
unpopular to the to the degree that
people are
uh not so much resisting your message
but critical of of your approach
you force you force the recognition that
that no has to be said in order to make
progress forward and that
that interferes with a utop with an
imaginary utopian vision
but it it and it and so that makes
that makes romanticizing the venture
much more difficult
it doesn't seem impossible though i mean
you could imagine a
a heart rending and emotionally
compelling video
addressing the utility of restoring
to health someone who was suffering from
tuberculosis or preventing it in the
first place i mean
these things don't seem completely
impossible you haven't found any
marketing or advertising agency that's
willing to partner
with you in in in the sale of any of
these
ideas we found lots of people who
who love to jump on board and you know
look look there are lots of videos out
there that
that tells you how incredibly important
it is to do something that tuberculosis
and how important it is to do something
about maternal health and
and about immunization and about malaria
and all these other things
i i think it's much more a question of
saying what is it that you
overwhelmingly see when you see open you
know your tv
or you look at youtube and i think
there's just a
level difference in the amount of
knowledge that you have about
tuberculosis
compared to the amount of knowledge that
you have about covet certainly now
and about climate change and these other
things it's just simply a question of
saying
one of them or the the two last ones
resonate
much much clearer to most people and to
a lot of
uh interest organizations whereas the
other one is sort of that
yeah of course i also think we should do
some tuberculosis
now back to what we were talking about
before yeah
so the climate the other the issue with
regards to the climate is that
the weather affects everyone all the
time
if you're going to talk about some if
you're going to talk to someone
and you don't really know what to talk
about you'll make small talk about the
weather
and so it's an immediate day-to-day
concern in a way that even
infectious disease isn't or wasn't
before kovid
and so maybe that's another reason that
the the climate
issue has been has occupied the
the the space for apocalyptic attention
if there is a
too hot summer or an extraordinarily hot
summer you have an explanation for it
and it's something that affects you
while it's happening or a too cold
winter day or too much wind or too much
rain or
you know any of the extreme weather
events that can manifest themselves
so there's an immediacy to weather that
seems to be associated perhaps with the
with the emotional resonance of climate
change that's also perhaps working
against these rational arguments
well there's certainly something so we
have research that shows that when
it's hot people believe more in global
warming than when it's cold
so there definitely is these kinds of
very very simple
uh uh uh connections on the other hand
if you think about
it when you talk about global warming
it's going to be
let's say four degrees centigrade hotter
in a hundred years that's actually
really hard to imagine that most people
would get very worked up about
and that's of course also what you saw
for the first 20 years or so
of global warming what has happened is
that shift
from the focus on the uh the basic
outcomes of global warming
to these catastrophic outcomes so that
every time you see a storm
every time you see a heat wave every
time
you see any kind of change in weather
people will often say
see global warming and there
the problem is that that leads you to
believe
this could be the end of the world right
and and and that's what
i think and that's universal explanatory
rubric and
and hard to so it buys you explanations
for
weather alterations and it buys you
moral virtue it buys you a sense that
you understand the most impor
important problems in the world and it
occupies that apocalyptic space
another reason that climate change might
have become such a concern
because you know people have always
believed in the apocalypse
and that's because things can go
cataclysmically wrong
and and maybe we have a we have a need
for a cultural representation of that
and
before global warming we had this the
cold war and the
and the battle between the united states
or the west more broadly speaking in the
soviet union that was a pretty plausible
apocalypse and
of course it did garner much more
attention or maybe an
amount of attention that's equal to the
attention that global warming
attracts now so
that doesn't solve the the sales and
marketing problem
um it just highlights its its difficulty
can can i ask you i noticed you have
these prioritizes books bangladesh
priorities
haiti prioritizes andhra pradesh
prioritizes
now you've opened up your economic team
to use by states
correct yes can you tell us a little bit
about that
that's another that's something else
that's extremely practical and i'd like
to know how you do it and
what the effect is does it work yes
yes so so uh one of the things we found
uh so we did a prioritization of the
sustainable development goals for the un
that we talked about in the beginning uh
and and
what's what's sort of very noticeable is
if you talk about what should the world
do
everybody thinks that's intellectually
interesting but nobody feels like they
live in the world you know they
well we're canada we're the us or
denmark or whatever
and so you feel like i want something
that's actually relevant for
my political conversation and so one of
the things we wanted to do we we also
did this in latin america
uh with the inter-american development
bank and we found you know these are
some of the best things to do in latin
america
and then you know obviously argentina
would say yeah that's probably true in
mexico but not here we're special and
and likewise brazil would say yeah
that's true in argentina but not here
so you know the const you could
constantly get the sense of it's true
somewhere else but not here and that's
why we wanted to have this conversation
specifically for nations so we've done
this for bangladesh we've done this for
two states in india on the pradesh and
rajasthan
we've done it in haiti we've just
completed this in ghana and africa and
we're
right now working with malawi that must
be ridiculously
exciting and interesting i mean it's
such a combination of
rich intellectual possibility because
these problems are so compelling
and and the the potential excitement of
actually operating in the real world yes
it is very exciting it's also at times
very frustrating as you i'm sure you
could imagine
uh so so uh what happens is
everybody thinks that this is a great
idea in principle
but of course everyone worries also what
if my
favorite things turn out to be not a
very good investment
that's suddenly gonna you know make it
much harder for me to
get money for next from next year's
budget so there's this right there's
this
uh sense of do we want this to be too
successful
on the other hand the finance ministry
often loves this
approach because they're the ones who
get inundated from
all ministries and saying we need more
money for this project we need more
money for that project
and of course politicians also need uh
projects
that sell essentially buy some votes
and so clearly they're also very
ambivalent about this on the one hand
they want to do as much good as they can
for their country on the other hand
often the best political promises
are the ones that are not very effective
they're the ones that
you can sell because they sound good but
don't actually work very well
uh you can put off endlessly and still
promise that you're going to deliver
or or just deliver and do it really
badly so in india for instance
uh one of the things that i've turned
out to be incredibly good vote for
winners is to give uh forgiveness
for loans for small fo smallhold farmers
uh you can imagine how that you know if
if i'm a farmer
i've put myself in almost uh impossible
debt
there's a politician who promises he's
going to forgive that
that sounds great but of course the
problem with that argument
is that partly they often don't pay but
what happens is it actually
ends up shifting loaning from the
very poorest to the not so poor farmers
typically to the rather rich farmers
because the lenders don't want to see
the politicians ending up saying no
we're not gonna uh
uh uh keep your your loans on uh
on the books so you end up spending huge
amounts of money
encouraging bad loans and then not
helping
uh the the poor when they need it
further on
that's a lose-lose-lose outcome
and one of the things we tried to point
out was don't do that
i'm sure we weren't very successful
because it's an incredibly
successful political strategy but it
becomes a little harder to do
and likewise some of the things that we
found were incredibly effective
becomes a little easier to do so for
instance for
for bangladesh we found and again this
is not
this is not dramatic news but it's just
a really really good
uh approach to uh to basically
put your procurement online uh so
for many states in the developing
countries uh procurement makes up about
one-third to two-thirds of their budgets
so everything from pencils to roads
but obviously roads are much much more
expensive so it's typically
infrastructure projects
they're dramatically uh corrupt
because they lend themselves to be very
corrupt and one of the things we find is
if you put these online it becomes a
little harder to rig
the auctions so in bangladesh for
instance you have to
hand in a sealed envelope with your bid
to a specific government office and what
not surprisingly happened was
they put up goons outside that office so
the people
who shouldn't come in with a cheap bid
just couldn't physically come in
if you put it online you can get bids
from further afar it's harder to
manipulate you can still manipulate
but it gets harder to do so so what we
found was we
we took four percent of bangladesh
spending put it online
and actually found you get higher
quality you get it much cheaper
that means you have to spend less money
you get more for your
government tax dollars or taxes as in
in bangladesh and that saves bangladesh
about 700 million dollars a year
right so but there's something else
that's very hard to romanticize
you know oh it's absolutely impossible
and
and and again remember this is simply a
question of saying
we look across a wide range of things
that you could do in bangladesh
some of these things got picked up by
politicians because they
save the money obviously the finance
minister wants to save 700 million
dollars
some of these things have really really
good long-term growth potentials
like for instance getting digitized
you're getting your land
digitized some of these are very obvious
things like uh
tuberculosis but many of them also don't
happen
just simply because they're not the
right
set of things to do right now so again
our point is not that we somehow
magically make bangladesh right that
would also be
impossible to imagine and and look you
shouldn't have
you know economists prioritizing the
world you should have economists
informing the electorate in bangladesh
how do you want to run your country
but we help make slightly better some of
the proposals
help spend slightly less money really
badly
and overall that means you end up in a
place where you're better off yeah it
doesn't make a good t-shirt slogan no
does it
it doesn't spend your money slightly
less badly with bjorn
yeah no it's a real problem you know
i've been talking i talked
about this a little bit with douglas
murray just a week or so ago
um about the about the rise of extremism
um well it's a continual problem but
the polarization of the right and the
left that seems to be
occurring at an ever escalating rate
particularly in the u.s but i would say
in the west more broadly
um we talked about the collapse of grand
narratives you know the right the
centrists on the right and the centrists
on the left
don't seem to have anything to offer now
except
something like incremental and
gradualist improvement and they might
quibble about how that could be
accomplished with the right wingers
taking one viewpoint and the left
wingers taking another
whereas the radicals have a much more
romantic cell
and so since the right and the left the
moderates can't come up with a
narrative even one of progress that's
i think you know back say in the
post-war period post-world war ii
people were still poor enough broadly
speaking so that you could sell them the
vision of a
a wealthier future for them and their
kids
and there was enough gap between where
they were and that hypothetical future
for it to be motivating but
now you know you might be able to tell
your
your your uh electorate that well we
could make things 20
better over the next 10 years and that's
true and it's good but it's not punchy
and that's a big problem and i've been
struggling i also talked to
mac um to matt ridley you know he's he's
a
guy i think who thinks like you um
you know he's fundamentally optimistic
in his view and he thinks things are
getting better and that we could
continue to make them better
and that we should continue to make them
better but
all of this incremental gradualism
this optimistic incremental gradualism
has the same problem which is it's
difficult to get excited about it
and i don't know i've racked my brains
trying to figure out
how that might be how that problem might
be addressed but i can't say that i've
come up with any
solutions that seem useful or credible
i don't i'd like you to comment on that
i'm sure you've thought about it i i
think you're absolutely right it's
it is much much harder to make the
argument look we're going to muddle
through it's going to be a little bit
better this is a little bit smarter
please do this rather than these very
grand
narratives and i think that's exactly
what i try to make with global warming
the grand narrative and global warming
is this is the end of the world we've
got to throw everything in the kitchen
sink at this
and the reality is no this is a
problem you know we estimate that by the
end of the century this will cost us
about four percent
of gdp so maybe one or two years of
growth
that's a problem not by any
reasonable means the end of the world
and that's why you need to be careful
not to end up spending lots lots more
to tackle part of this problem but the
reality of course is
if we go down the route of these very
alluring
but incorrect arguments this is the end
of the world you know let's spend
everything on climate change
what really could happen is two things
we
end up spending lots of our resources on
things that are not very productive and
won't leave us very well off that will
cut
maybe half or a fuller maybe one and a
half percent of gdp growth
from our growth rate that could be
potentially
dramatically damaging in 10 20 30 years
once we're a lot less richer a lot less
better off because remember one of the
things that keeps societies peaceful
is that we all have a future to look
forward to that's going to be much
better
once we start realizing we're entering
into a stable state
where if you are better off it's because
i'm less well-off
we will get much much more antagonism
so i think it's realistic to say if we
follow down those alluring roads we
might actually end up leaving our future
of our grandkids much less
better off not just in the economic
sense but also just simply
in a wildly sort of rioting kind of way
that everybody will be
at each other's throat that's one part
of it but the other part is to remember
we're right now talking about how the
west or the rich part of the world
thinks about this problem most people in
the rich world actually think the the
future is going to be a lot worse off
which is one of the reasons why
global warming fits into that whole
pattern i think it's wrong that's also
what the model said that it's even what
the human climate panel says but that's
how people feel
the other three quarters of the world
which are
china india latin america africa
they actually believe that their world
is going to be much better
in 10 20 30 years they have this future
belief that you were just talking about
from from out of the second world war
they
are not going to say yeah we're going to
do
strong climate uh policy and become poor
they want to mostly become middle-income
countries and maybe even rich countries
eventually
they will want to do this so what will
happen is both that we're leaving
ourselves in the rich world
to become much more infighting and much
less well-off than we otherwise would be
and that we're actually seeing the other
three quarters of the world just simply
running
uh you know possibly even ahead of us
but certainly
uh running ahead without looking at the
same kind of problems that we are
okay so do you think do you think you
could make this case so what you
basically outlined there is a hypothesis
that
ill-spent money will have dramatic
consequences
i think i can make that argument but i
also feel a little uncomfortable
i'm i'm just the guy who wants to tell
you you can spend a little smarter here
you can spend a little more dumb here
i think there's something there's
something i think that's a little sort
of
ugly in in saying all right everybody
else is making up their own uh
uh uh doomsday scenarios so let
me make up uh another one here because i
think fundamentally doomsday scenarios
is what got us into these
look fair enough but you you you were
trying to address the problem of
of compounding returns right so bad
economic decisions or poorer economic
decisions compound with time
and so
is it reasonable to point out when we're
talking about risk
i talked with matt ridley about this and
i've thought about it a fair bit as well
and i think the data support the
proposition that
making poor people richer is an
extremely intelligent environmental move
for a variety of reasons i mean the
first is perhaps that once you get
people
above a certain level of income they can
start
buying fuels that are cleaner than the
fuels they learn they use now
um dung and wood and that kind of thing
but also that as people move up the
economic hierarchy
they have time to be concerned about
things that are more abstract like
what the environment is going to be like
for their children which they're not
going to be
or or when they go on holiday for
example you know or even where they live
as
as they have some options to choose
where to live
and so it it could be
you know we often construe
the relationship between the economy and
the environment as a zero-sum game
right and the biologists in particular
broadly speaking have
the political biologists have a
proclivity to do that
that as the economy grows we sacrifice
the environment to it
but it could be the case that
we get the best environmental bang for
the buck by
making the poor rich as fast as we
possibly can around the world
and and if we make poor economic
decisions because we're
catastrophizing a certain kind of
environmental calamity we're inviting
we're actually increasing the risk of of
environmental degradation in
in the medium and the long term do you
think that's reasonable
yes absolutely so in a number of
different ways so
i i think it's funny how we don't
recognize
how terrible it is to be poor if you're
poor
you're vulnerable in all kinds of ways
you're very clearly
incredibly vulnerable to global warming
so you know uh
if you remember there was a big
hurricane hitting high on uh
the philippines and back in 2013 it was
made a big deal out of
uh as global warming it hit this very
very poor city
who you know where most of their city uh
uh citizens
live on the corrugated roof not
surprisingly having a hurricane five
is terrible when you live under a
corrugated roof
the best way to help these people
obviously would be to lift them out of
poverty what actually is
we can see back in in the early part of
last century a similar hurricane hit and
eradicate about half the city
this time it was only about a 20th of
the city so
much much better because the city was
much richer but if we focused on making
them even richer
they would be much better off just
simply from the point of view
of being more protected from hurricanes
so
you know fundamentally there's something
weird about us saying oh those poor
people
in the philippines we should help them
by not driving our car today
what no you should help them by becoming
rich becoming part of the integrated
global economy making sure that their
kids would be better
better educated not die from easily
curable infectious diseases and so on
so not only would it be better
environmentally but it would obviously
also be better for them
educationally for them health wise and
all these other things
it would simply generate much much
better lives
in the phil uh in the philippines but
and as you also pointed out
as you get richer you're actually
cleaner and almost always
you don't use dung and cardboard and
wood to cook
inside but also you stop cutting down
forest
you move to the city instead you become
a web designer or something else that
very very little related to actually
clearing out
forest land you do a lot of things in
cities
that are much more ecologically
sustainable and of course in the long
run
you will actually also say i would like
to make sure that we have better
regulations
so we have less air pollution so we have
many of the other things
that drive environmental benefits so
absolutely
by getting people out of poverty we fix
most
environmental problems but and this is
the important but yeah we don't fix
global warming
as you get richer you just simply emit
more and more co2 because these guys
will then start flying around the world
they'll start you know
consuming a lot more meat they'll be
doing a lot of other things because
they're richer
that's wonderful for them but it will
mean higher
emissions of co2 so we do need to have a
conversation about how we're going to
fix
that problem okay so why don't you lead
us down that path
okay well let me let me comment a bit on
what you just said and then let's go
down that pathway
okay so to swallow what you just said
and to believe it
you you there's a set of beliefs that
you have to have
already in place you have to believe
that the current economic system
isn't fatally flawed and basically works
or at least works better than
any hypothetical alternatives that have
been tried or that we can dream up
so it basically works and works means as
it runs it tends to lift people out of
absolute poverty
there's still a maintenance of relative
poverty but absolute poverty tends to
disappear and there seems to be really
good evidence for that especially across
well since the industrial revolution but
it's really taken off in the last 30
years
maybe non-coincidentally with the demise
of
communism which was a competing you know
a competing
economic theory and and produced all
sorts of bad economic decisions
in any case you have to buy the
hypothesis that the current system works
and that extending it
is going to be better and so you don't
get to um
adopt revolutionary
a stance of revolutionary criticism of
the western capitalist
hierarchy so that's a big sacrifice if
if you were
if you're if your thinking is oriented
in that direction now
i don't know really what to make of that
because
you'd think the evidence that the poor
has been lifted out of poverty at an
unbelievable like an astonishing rate
since the year 2000
not just in china but but all over the
world
would be essentially irrefutable
evidence that
the current system and works and then if
you look at china
after they adopted free market policies
compared to before they adopted free
market policies there's absolutely no
comparison with regard to growth
and so it isn't obvious to me
how if you were truly concerned with the
poor you'd be able to
deny the sorts of propositions that you
put forward
i don't understand that maybe it's
partly because people just don't
know how much better things have gone
in the last 20 years and why you know
because it has been difficult news to
bring forward and
and it's difficult to market um
if i can just uh yes yes uh so
one of the things i think people don't
recognize if you look at it
at a graph of the last 200 years 200
years ago almost everyone in the world
were absolutely poor
in the sense of less less than a dollar
a day
yeah 95 of humanity was below that level
and we've just seen a dramatic decline
as you mentioned
we're now down below 10 even despite of
covet which a lot of people have pointed
out
have actually uh uh made more poor
people
uh we've gone from seven up to about
nine percent and so we've
delayed the uh the the benefit for a
couple of years that's terrible and i
would rather
not have had that happen but it doesn't
change the long-term trajectory that's
amazingly
downwards in the sense that we have many
many fewer people that are poor
uh one one of my favorite guys for uh
who runs the uh our world and data
uh website uh he points out
that every year for the last 25 years
the headline of every newspaper around
the world could have been
over the last 24 hours 138
000 people have lifted been lifted out
of poverty
138 000 people every day for the last
25 years but of course it's not news
because it happened
every day it was not you know some oh
this day it happened we don't get these
good news
and i think we need to get them in order
to be able to understand
the magnitude of what we're talking
about well you know the problem with
accepting that good news or a
problem with it is that it pretty much
eradicates the romantic rebel
you know because it all of a sudden
makes it very difficult for you to be
cool to find something cool to stand up
against
and to resist you know you have a
benevolent relatively benevolent society
that's getting incrementally better it's
not a villain that you can heroically
resist
and that's that is i'm not being cynical
about that that is actually a problem
because
resisting um arbitrary authority
is a good story and and it served people
well for
a very long time and if you don't have
that to
catalyze your identity you have to
search for something
perhaps equally grand and that's
difficult
especially when you also don't have to
go out and contend with
the brute force of mother nature to
anywhere near the degree that you once
had to
but but if you look at it there's plenty
of other things you could stand up to
and that was what we were talking to
instead of being the romantic hero that
stands up against society why aren't you
the romantic
hero that stands up against tuberculosis
or the one that stand up against
maternal death or the one that stands up
for free trade are the ones that stand
up
for all these other things where we know
for very little money
we can make a tremendous benefit so so
again i i get why it's not
hard man i mean i think it might have
something to do also with
the inability to utilize your resentment
you know if you're resentful about
things and you oppose
the capitalist state you can easily
identify an enemy but
if you stand up against tuberculosis
like obviously tuberculosis is bad it
doesn't make you
look good by comparison
all right so you mentioned you do
promote co2 emission amelioration
strategies
in false alarm and you did just point
out that
although we should be striving to make
the poor around the world as much less
poor as we possibly can as quickly as we
can
so everyone wins including us um
just like henry ford won when he paid
his workers enough to buy
his cars the cars they made um
they are going to increase their rate of
carbon
dioxide emission and for some people
that would be enough reason
to scrap the whole enrichment process
but you have some strategies that you
think are wise to ameliorate the
problems that would be associated with
that
yes so i i talk about five different
solutions in the book
so the first one is a carbon tax uh
any economist would say you know look
you have a problem
you emit co2 but you don't actually take
it into consideration because
it's free to emit so that's how we think
about
the polluter pays you put a price on
carbon
in principle you should do this across
the world you should do it so that it
slowly rises with time
it's the most efficient way to deal with
it there's two things we need to
recognize with it one is
it turns out to be very very hard
because it makes it very explicit to
people
that tackling global warming is actually
costly secondly
we know that politicians are just really
really bad at doing something
for a long time very consistently across
all areas what politicians typically end
up doing is
they'll put it on some things so you
know in many places in europe for
instance you have enormously high
taxes on cars and you have enormously
low
uh taxes on people who are good at uh
lobbying their governments for their
particular interest so you know
greenhouse gardeners uh greenhouse uh
growers don't have to pay uh the the
carbon tax because
that would make it really hard for them
to grow their you know tomatoes or
whatever
and and you can see how this happens
across a wide range of areas
so that's one part of the problem the
other part is
even if you do this really really well
it'll only solve a smaller part of the
problem
so you should do this we should focus on
on a carbon tax but we should also be
realistic this is not what's going to
fix climate change this will fix a
smaller part
of climate change so it's part of the
solution but it's not the most important
part
the second part and that's where i think
we actually have the biggest opportunity
is innovation uh so if you talk to
matt ridley this is certainly also his
uh his ballpark
but it's basically recognizing that most
things that we've solved in this world
are about innovation so you rarely get
people to
to solve a problem by saying i'm sorry
could you please not do all that
cool stuff that you like could you
please stop feeling good about all of
that
that really works out as a political
strategy
unfortunately that's typically what we
say could you please not fly not eat
meat
not do all these things could you please
have it a little hotter in the summer
and a little cooler in the winter
that's really really hard to sell to
most people
what you need is innovation and
let me just give you an example uh back
in the 1950s los
angeles was one of the most polluted
places on the planet
because there are lots and lots of cars
and they have the special
sort of geographical notion that just
leaves all of the pollution
inside this little basin of los angeles
it was terrible
uh to live there in many ways uh and
obviously the simple answer is to tell
tell people most of this came from cars
so the simple answer would be to say
stop driving your car of course if
you've ever met someone from los angeles
you know that that's not
a solution that's actually viable to
them well there aren't even any
sidewalks
no it's not you know really viable for
anyone
uh in in any city what did solve the
problem was
the innovation of the catalytic
converter this little thing that
cost money you put on the exhaust pipe
and then basically you have
much much cleaner cars that made it
possible for people to
keep their cars drive a lot and have
much much
cleaner air in los angeles now i'm not
saying everything is perfect in los
angeles and there's still
air pollution problems but it made it a
lot better
for very little money that's the way
that we need to solve global warming
if we could innovate the price of green
energy down below fossil fuels and this
green energy could be nuclear
it could be fusion energy it could be
solar or wind
with batteries it could be lots and
other uh
possible solutions if we could innovate
one or a few of these solutions down
below fossil fuels
everyone would switch you wouldn't need
sort of a you know paris accord where
you have to twist everybody's arm
let me ask you about that for a minute
so it's not
a straightforward matter to set up
governmental policy to
to to uh to support innovation
i mean innovation is a very abstract
idea and i've seen
much evidence of failure at the
governmental level here in canada
when when governments have set out to
foster entrepreneurship and to seed
you know the development of high-tech
industry for example generally it's a
cataclysmic failure
i mean obviously it's self-evident in
some sense that
a good idea is good because it solves a
complicated problem and the more good
ideas we have the better
but do you think that it's like it seems
on the face of it
unless you dig down into the details it
seems like hand waving
obviously we should have better ideas to
solve our problems
but you what do you think constitute
concrete realistic evidence-based
solutions to
the problem of fostering innovation do
you think it's actually possible to set
up policy that does that
yes so the short answer is yes and and
and the reason is
that what what what's lacking is mostly
long-term investment so investment
that will only generate the solutions in
20 30 40 years
remember uh this is why we invest a lot
of money
in health care of basic
research that then eventually becomes
research
that you know for instance
pharmaceuticals can make into products
that they can make money off of
there's always a uh too little
investment
societally in things that you can't
monetize
right away so it's very hard to invest
in things that you can't monetize right
away
yes if i make an innovation that then in
20 years say
will help us generate this enormously
beneficial breakthrough
unfortunately i won't get any money
because my patent has run out
that's why most companies will not be
investing in these long-term
development what happens is that you
then have a
darth of investment into these terms
these sorts of long-term uh innovations
unless you have the public invest in
them and i'll get back to
how we do that smartly okay but we do
that
in medical research for many reasons you
know people recognize this is
part of the place where we need to you
know produce lots of professors lots of
medical noble alerts
and then you know eventually the
pharmaceuticals will take over
and actually make products out of this
that's a great setup
we don't do this in energy for a variety
of reasons
it is one of the places where we spend
very very little money
partly because it doesn't feel like
you're solving global warming because
you're not solving it right now you're
only solving it in
you know 20 or 40 years that feels like
you didn't really care
but the reality is this is the only way
that we're going to get these sorts of
long-term breakthroughs
now one reason why politicians often
screw this up is because they are not
willing to invest in these long-term
investments they'll say we want a you
know a silicon valley
in canada in three years um yeah that
makes sense if you need to get
re-elected and four
but you can't do that and and so you
shouldn't be
trying to do this in a very short-term
way
another way is that you end up giving
this away to companies
uh and companies of course are just
going to spend it on the product that
they were going to do next year anyway
uh but hey thanks for the money so the
the point here is you need to do this
carefully in a way
that will generate long-term uh
innovation
this is not easy you are going to waste
a lot of money but we
know that governments around the world
has done this in a variety of different
ways
uh we know for instance the you know the
internet the uh uh
the transistor uh the uh uh
fracking in the u.s there's a number of
places where you have been successful
and
all we have to do is to spend lots of
money and and i'd love to talk more
about
specifically how we should set this up
how we should evaluate and we should be
careful about it
but fundamentally we should do this in a
way that we say we want to generate a
lot of knowledge that we believe in the
long run can
deliver benefits that will actually help
companies produce energy that will be
viable
but we are not going to try and do this
for the next three or five years
so we've got to stop that panic mode and
start this long-term thinking
we do have realistic uh knowledge about
both that we're investing very little
compared to typical typically almost all
other areas
and that more investment here would make
it more plausible that we would
faster get cheaper green energy so
okay so in canada there's a medical
research council and a social sciences
research council in the natural sciences
and engineering research council
that might be a bit dated that
information but essentially that's how
it's been set up
but there isn't an energy innovation
research council
and you know we i'm thinking that way
because i'm an academic and i've seen
these granting agencies
i've seen how they work and they're set
up to provide funds for basic research
um and and something like that doesn't
exist
so what's why
why aren't we funding research into
energy into into the generation of cheap
and and clean
energy what what what's what's going
away
every year we want to spend it on
solar panels that makes us feel like
we're doing something right now
the the surprising thing is in 2015
when all countries signed the paris uh
climate agreement on the sidelines of
that
uh event obama and 20 other
global leaders bill gates and lots of
billionaires actually signed another
agreement that i'm happy to say we were
a tiny part of
pushing which was we're going to double
our investment into green energy
research and development so all
countries both
promised the thing that you heard about
namely we're going to cut
our carbon emissions but they also
promised to
double their green energy investment in
five years so in 2020
they did quite a bit of the cutting
carbon emissions
they did nothing of the increased
spending in green energy r d and i think
fundamentally because
it doesn't feel like a solution it
doesn't feel like something urchin it
feels like something you can do next
year
it feels like something that's nice to
have but this you know putting up the
solar panel
is urgent and we need to do it the
reality is
the over worry about global warming that
we have because we're
you know we have this existential feel
that this could be the end of the world
surprisingly also not only is wrong but
it also leads us down the wrong path
namely the path where we say let's do
anything that just makes it look like
we're doing something
next year rather than actually laying
the groundwork
for fixing this problem now obviously
and some people will say well we should
have done this 20 years ago and yes
that would be wonderful we should have
done that but we didn't you know it's
sort of too late to do something about
what we should have done
20 years ago but we can do something
about what we're going to spend our
money on
in 2021 and if you look for instance on
biden's proposal to fix climate change
he's he's thinking about spending two
trillion dollars you'll
probably not get to spend all that money
on a
vast array of things many of which are
not going to be very effective
but he's also saying he wants to
dramatically increase actually
i think probably too much but certainly
a very very large amount
of increase in american spending on r d
this is what he should be focusing on
but i do worry
that he's going to end up having much
more success with all his other
much less effective proposals simply
because they are more glamorous
all right so um you
don't seem to be an admirer of the paris
accords
and so my sense of your argument is that
the proposals that are part of that
accord are extremely expensive
and they're not cost effective
especially when viewed in this larger
framework
that encompasses a whole host of
problems instead of focusing just on
climate change
and so maybe if if you don't mind you
could
summarize your could you lay out your
critique of the paris accords
for for us yes so so two things
the paris agreement is really just an
extension of what we've been trying for
the last 30 years and
failed to do the last 30 years namely
let's try
to do something that's really hard that
costs a lot of money that will have a
little bit of impact in a hundred years
and try and see if we can't get
everybody to do it not surprisingly
that's a really really hard
thing to get and to do what and to do
what exactly so so basically get
canada get the us get denmark get
everybody else
to cut their carbon emissions which
privately for them
is going to be costly they have to uh
you know reduce their use of of cheap
energy and
use a little bit more expensive energy
sometimes less reliable energy
basically it puts us a slight slower
damper on their economic growth that's
always going to be hard
that's always going to be unpopular
you're basically asking people
could you please pay some more and use a
little bit less
that's that's a hard sell not
surprisingly you do a little bit of it
you typically don't do a lot of it you
don't live up to all of your promises
but even if you do so let's just take
the paris agreement even if
everyone did everything they promised to
that would cut as much co2 that if you
run it through a climate model
it would cut temperatures by
point zero two five degrees centigrade
by the end of the century
so literally nothing we wouldn't be
comparing
magnitude of increase so it's about four
degrees
uh of uh temperature rise we've already
seen one so about three
three degrees more so this would be a
trivial part
of reduction now it would be a reduction
it would mean we would have less
problems because global warming is a
problem
so we estimate there would be benefits
but there would also be huge costs
because you'd actually have to pay for
this
so if you look at how much you're going
to pay which is
in the order of 1 to 2 trillion u.s
dollars per year in 2030
for every dollar spent you will avoid
climate damages across the centuries
worth about 11 cents that's a very poor
way of spending money
paying a dollar and actually achieving
11 cents you could just have paid out
the dollar and
and done you know almost 10 times as
much good in the world
so the reality here is the paris
agreement is a really well-intentioned
agreement
but it will fail just like all the other
agreements so you know
rio uh kyoto and all the other
national policies that we've done it'll
mostly fail but
even if it succeeded it would be a very
expensive way of achieving very little
and this of course is the big problem of
the climate conversation
that because we're so worried we've
decided
yeah we're not going to spend all that
much money on all these other problems
in the world tuberculosis all this other
stuff
but we are going to spend one to two
trillion dollars remember it's not going
to bring us to the poor house but it's a
lot of money
it's one to two percent of global gdp on
something that will basically not bias
any measurable impact in a hundred years
that's a bad deal that's why we need to
do better
okay well that's a that's a good place
to sum up i would say if
unless you think there's something
particularly important that we didn't
cover
i would have liked to have heard perhaps
more
description of you know you listed out
the top four things or the top five
things that we could be investing in
where there's a huge bang for the buck
but people can get that directly from
your website or your book
so yes and we've i've shown you this
before
but we have a whole folder i'm sure you
can put that up uh where you can
actually see all the different
uh investments here yeah and you can see
foreign
so so um i've been talking with bjorn
lomberg today
the author of false alarm and we've been
talking about
global governance i would say
sustainable global governance with an
emphasis on two things and one would be
um economic growth which means
alleviation of absolute poverty for
those who are poorest and some
incremented wealth
hypothetically for the rest of us which
seems on the face of it to be a good
thing
especially at the lower ends of the
distribution and uh
discussing also how that might be done
in the most appropriate ecological
manner
keeping in mind the host of other
problems that have to be solved
and uh dr lomborg has developed a
methodology for
assessing and rank ordering
the problems that we face at an
international level and as well at a
national level
um i'm going to interrupt my summary for
one thing how
what's been what's been your experience
with regards to your success in those
countries where you've gone in and done
this prioritization what's been the
practical consequence of that
so we've very clearly so
we're an organization look at how
effective are you so obviously we should
be looking at how effective are we
yes in what we do also you know i'm i'm
using my life in this i'd like to know
that actually has an impact
uh so yes we are effective uh so what we
found
as in these countries will change some
of those policies
and we'll change them somewhat towards
being smarter
not by any means the whole way or
anything sure but
towards better spending and because most
nation-states
spends billions of dollars on making
lives for their
own citizens better if they just change
a little bit
of their increased spending as they get
richer over the years
that will have a much much bigger impact
so it should
give you a sense of proportion the whole
project that we do costs about two and a
half million dollars
and we probably have impacts in the uh
you know we change
hundreds of millions of dollars possibly
billions of dollars in spending
and each one of those dollars will have
impacts in the order of
you know somewhere between five and up
to twenty or thirty dollars more
well off okay so that's that's great you
know because
what that actually indicates is that a
rationally designed
program aimed at incremental gradual
improvement
actually works extraordinarily well it
isn't revolutionary by any stretch of
the imagination but
as a strategy it pays off
extraordinarily handsomely i wish i
for many reasons that i hadn't been so
ill for the last while
because i was going to lobby hard for
the utilization of your team here in
ontario and
and in canada and i suppose that could
still happen in the future
hypothetically but
i'm very very pleased to hear that the
consequences have been
positive and also that you had the
fortitude and methodological
integrity to include an evaluation of
your own process
in your evaluation process there's a
rule for social science intervention
which is almost never followed which is
don't intervene without assessing the
outcome of your intervention
it's a mistake it's it's an ethical
error and can have terrible practical
consequences
okay so so back to the summary so
bjorn's team has rank ordered and
prioritized a whole set of global
concerns
they've also started to work at the
state level the country level instead of
the international level
as we just discussed that's also paid
off um
and all of this lays out a lovely
pathway i would say for people who
for people to inform themselves
about those issues that they could adopt
as
salient to themselves politically and
ideologically to provide
some meaning for their life some
practical meaning and to actually
further the development
further positive development in a whole
host of areas
and so if you're interested in that as
the viewer listener then i'd
highly recommend bjorn's books and but
more importantly his approach and
and some intelligent investigation as to
the
methods of that approach and the
consequences and so
um more power to you as far as i'm
concerned
um that's for sure and i'm was very
pleased as always to talk with you
is there anything else that you'd like
to tell people before
so if if you wouldn't mind i'd i'd love
to just uh because i
i tried to go through the five things
that you can do so i'm just gonna really
quickly uh mention the last three is
that yes
yes and then i'd i'd love to also make
one more point about my book
but okay you know so we talked about a
carbon tax
and innovation innovation is crucial uh
you should also focus on adaptation
uh it's sort of an uh naughty word
in much of the conversation in global
warming but very clearly adaptation is
going to be one of the big ways
that we're going to fix many of the
problems it's going to happen to a large
extent simply because people do that
if you're a farmer you're going to plant
later or earlier depending on the
the climate changes and eventually you
might plant something else
you should also look at geoengineering
we talked about that very
briefly but basically the idea of saying
if there were to be a really
catastrophic
impact geoengineering is basically a way
of making sure that you can restore
the temperature of the earth very
quickly at fairly low cost
we should not just go ahead with it but
we should certainly be thinking about it
and and that's all i'm going to say
about this right now the last bit and we
also talked
extensively about that is to make sure
that prosperity is also
a big solution to climate change most of
the things that you're impacted with
you're impacted with because you're poor
if you're really poor
everything hits you hard but climate
hits you hard as well
if you're rich you're much much less
impacted and so very clearly
the question is do we want to help
bangladesh a little bit
by cutting carbon emissions and
basically then leaving them poor but hey
at least sea levels rose this much less
by the end of the century
or would we rather make sure that we
actually leave bangladesh much richer
which means that they'll be much better
able to handle hurricanes that they'll
be much better able to handle
sea level rise and so on there's a very
strong
basis of evidence that shows that
prosperity is actually much better
for most countries not just because it's
wonderful in all kinds of other ways you
can avoid your kids dying and
make get the better education and all
these other things but also for climate
so those were the five points and
innovation is by far
the most important thing i just want to
say one last thing about you know
because my book is very much uh we've
talked a lot about all the big problems
in the world
the reason why i talk about global
warming is because
it is the one thing that i that i
experience
most people actually talking about all
the time is this existential threat this
is the big thing that we should all be
concerned about
certainly a lot of people the un uh
secretary general many others are
telling us
this is the top priority for humanity
because if this is going to eradicate
all of us surely this
should be the thing that we focus on i
think that
that makes intellectual sense if it was
true but that's not what the un climate
panel is telling us
it's not what the science is telling us
it tells us this is a problem
by no means the end of the world and
that is not only important because
you can't really get to all the other
things we were talking about
unless you stop believing this is the
end of the world
if this is the end of the world you are
going to set everything else aside
but also of course it's the only way
that you can actually get a better life
uh you know when you see all these kids
uh being really worried about
am i gonna have a future when i grow up
uh people believing
literally that humanity is going to end
that must be
terrible now if it was true we should be
telling people but it's not true
and therefore being able to relieve
yourself from that
scare is also really really valuable on
a personal level
so this book was written not just to
make sure
that you can get rid of the scare but
also that you can start realizing this
is a problem among many others
now let's think about how do we
prioritize and and that's what i'm
i'm hoping this conversation will help
us so in a sense you could say
the false alarm book is a stepping stone
to be able to have that
you know more general conversation
namely what is it that the world should
be prioritizing
if we're not scared withless about
global warming but actually
sees it see it as it is a problem among
many problems
great well that's a really good place to
end so um
thanks very much and i hope we get a
million people to watch this and
another 500 thousand to listen to it
we'll see how it goes
so thanks very much for talking to me
today bjorn it was a pleasure
uh listening to you i always learn a lot
reading your books
listening to you and and uh it's been a
it's been
well it's very nice to come across
sources of realistic hope
you know and that's what your books
provide they provide sources of
realistic hope man those are in short
supply
so um even though there's lots of
reasons to be hopeful and
perhaps the supply shouldn't be so short
but it's nice to be able to maintain
critical intelligence and not to have to
descend into a well of pessimism as a
consequence
yes it's wonderful to talk to you and
it's always
you give me a lot of different uh uh
perspectives on what we're doing which
is just as valuable
you know you're sort of you're stuck in
your own little uh uh
way of thinking about this and it's
wonderful to sort of be able to say oh
yeah yeah there are all these other
perspectives and
all these ways that you also need to to
have that conversation that's great so
it's always wonderful to talk to you
thank you
[Music]
you